[Music]
a benon thank you so much for joining me
startup Nation United um very um
difficult days for us to do while we're
doing this recording on October 29th
past three weeks um I don't think any of
us could have expected them the way they
are H your company and you as an
entrepreneur as a serial entrepreneur um
you really you're you're the C
focal point of the startup Nation story
and the
ecosystem um and um big inspiration to
to many and both entrepreneurs investors
and employees can testify and and an
inspiration for myself so um I'm I'm
very interested in hearing how you've
adapted over the last three weeks how
you've experienced what's been happening
here your company is a hyper Growth
Company in the Israeli cyber security
scene and so obviously this is hugely
relevant and the day today is October
29th and it's three weeks after the the
the everything that happened so over
again thank you for being here tell me
right before we get started into the
context of the war and the what happened
who are you in a couple words and tell
me a little bit about
Talent sure so uh hi uh first definitely
uh really really complicated uh few
weeks it's been
uh no I I think none of us in in our
worst nightmares could have been uh
expecting that or imagining that uh um
each one of us obviously knows someone
or knows someone who knows many uh or
many that know someone um none of us
could have imagined this so um obviously
our prayers are for the ones that uh uh
hopefully will come back soon uh to
Israel more than anything else and our
hearts um goes with with the family to
blost someone so um super complicated
days said more than anything else uh
hoping for for much better and stable
days um my name is offer offer benon I'm
the co-founder and CEO of Talon uh Talon
is a secure Enterprise browser uh we'
have been the pioneer of this uh newly
formed category uh um we have today
about 140 employees
globally um we have many many thousands
of uh of C of customers today uh and and
the logic of Talon is uh when everything
is moving uh to the web uh the browser
is becoming actually uh the entry point
for for the organization and kind of the
choke point for everything uh that our
employees contractor third party are
doing uh when touching pretty much our
data so instead of surrounding the
browser we so many different security
tools uh we are actually shifting from
the browser as the problem to having it
actually the
solution uh uh for the global Workforce
uh and all of the in the organization
and
externals um providing everything from
web security uh data leage prevention
Insider thread uh device posture uh Etc
uh was bringing the top enterpr browser
to the market
that's well it's a I I'll just mention
for for context because we have a lot of
people that are that are tuning in that
are not from necessarily the ecosystem
you know all for you as an entrepreneur
and the company itself is really the you
know the the startup Nation story you
know we've had stories of Neta in the
older ages and the different you know
inspiring Israeli companies that have
emerged and you're really are
representation of the newly emerging the
the new generation of of the of
inspiring cation companies so thank you
first of all for that as I mentioned
before but you know take me to where you
were on October 7th you know morning you
know everything that happened and then
I'm I'm very curious to hear you know
what's going through your mind now as a
CEO as a leader of a 140 person
organization you know what is what's
happening and how do you even navigate
through
that so it was uh Saturday morning um
and and typically uh um because most of
our customers are in in in the US so I I
typically work quite late so remember
working until 3:00 a.m. on a Friday
night uh planning to wake up at around
probably 9:00
a. um on on Saturday uh 7 am. uh my wife
Dan W me up off off years to wake up uh
you you learn the divorce happening so
what like said oh it seems Seems like uh
uh terrorists uh from from Hamas
organization have been uh uh H uh
penetrating into Israel and uh uh
conducting uh Massac it do make sense to
me um and then you know the news come in
and and and and and uh the videos of on
on on social networks and and understand
that this nightmare that I initially
thought is just a
nightmare um is is the reality and it
was
unbelievable uh so after you were trying
to to grasp the situation to understand
that this is not just
imagination I you remind yourself okay I
I just second I mean now to see what
that everyone from my employees are okay
from uh everything that is um the family
right everything that happens around the
friends all right so kind of you
immediately uh try to get a grasp of
okay let's move from from the shop into
operational
mode um understanding that uh everything
is up in terms of the systems the
customers everything is
perfect uh in terms
of uh the service the company uh and as
fast as possible to make sure that that
everyone around us uh are are okay to
start you know immediate uh
communication so you have a lot of
employees that obviously are lead in the
south of Israel and to make sure that uh
we get as as wide communication as
possible uh and to assess the situation
uh and we've been quite fortunate to
know that uh um no one from first degree
uh uh uh of of the company employees has
been uh harmed and and that was a big
relief um yeah that was mainly uh our
October 7th so perhaps grateful that no
nobody from first were were first party
harmed but I I think part of the the
what we've all experienced that every
person in Israel and every person
connected to Ser na knows firsthand
somebody that was directly impacted and
so all of a sudden you have you know as
a leader an organization with a lot of
people that are now you know are now
dealing with this what what do you do as
a leader at that moment how do you what
do you communicate how do you how are
you starting to even plan what are you
going to do over the next few days and
weeks because like you mentioned you
have you know you have customers all
over the world hyper grow company ey is
on you right Spotlight right now now how
what do you
do so I think uh uh the second that we
kind of
understood the situation uh then we try
to understand okay how do we operate and
then we kind of had three different uh
uh verticals that that we've been
operating on the first one is uh um
making sure that we are 100% of the
business continuity that all of our
systems everything works as expected and
I'll touch this in in a couple of
minutes uh the second
vertical uh is around uh supporting our
employees uh at the end of the day we
have a full responsibility for them and
we need to make sure that we can support
them in the best possible way and the
third one is as an Israeli company we
want to support as as as best as we can
uh the Israel population and and U
making uh pretty much the the challenge
es that everyone here are facing and and
the people are in a much bigger
challenge compared to us as as much of
support and Aid as as we can and I can
touch each one of the three
verticals well let's go into them one by
one and I'd love to dive deeper into
these three into these three verticals
and how you've thought through them and
then operationally also what you did um
more t on the
ground perfect so let's start with kind
of the um business uh uh operations uh I
think you would have been a little bit
probably more fortunate because the
company is a little bit more uh in in a
growth space so uh uh today we are
already a global company we have about
40 uh 50 people outside of uh of Israel
so um that allowed us to operate a
little bit uh uh uh faster and stronger
making sure that pretty much there is no
uh harm at all in in the service that we
provide our customers so uh the focus of
business continuity of course and
residency is critic on this uh
situation um we make sure that broad
employees uh are covering completely for
the Israeli ones so anywhere or the
sales operations uh customer
success uh is is happening mainly right
now in different uh regions uh and the
other side is to make sure that we have
enough of uh devops uh capacity and
Engineering outside of Israel for
anything else that is uh uh that is
needed uh having after that you have
kind of okay make sure I have everything
that is needed uh operationally the
second stage is to make sure that we
also communicate this and give this
Comfort to our customers because um
while we say and feel hey everything is
is okay and stable not necessarily our
customers understand the same and and
they need that assurances learn so and
I'm sure that everybody's looking at the
news and the whole world is this is you
know we we've become a spotlight for the
entire world right now so I can only
imagine the daily phone calls and emails
that you're getting and even if you're
not getting them that's what they're
thinking yeah so I can tell you the
first the customers have been amazing
amazing like I couldn't have imagined
better the only thing that they've
communicated with me in the first few
days is hey how are you
is everything okay is there anything
that we can support like honestly I
think in the first 24 hours no one have
communicated with you is me asking um is
the company still functional the only
communication only communication was hey
we've seen
this um we're supporting you guys can we
do something for you which is it's been
amazing amazing amazing we by far the
best customers someone can ever imagine
um having said that we made sure that
our customer success teams are
communicating with each and every single
one of our customers we have issued a
newsletter explaining uh uh how we are
uh making sure that our business
continuity and
resilience uh is is 100% and uh also
written uh a Blog so anyone can uh uh uh
see the activities and get uh the com
for but I think that there are kind of
for that kind of the two sides a you
need to make sure that everything is
okay but also you need to communicate it
uh well to reduce uh the discomfort or
the concerns on on the customer side uh
I can tell you that uh uh um also I feel
that for many of the
employees um also to myself focusing on
work really allows me to distract myself
a little bit from the said
reality uh and and I find that this is
really helpful for for for many
um uh because you know watching the news
all day long not necessarily um helps
the mental situation of anyone so uh so
you need to kind of balance that in uh
uh in a way and I feel that right now
three weeks in we're really able to to
find the the routine uh that allows us
to work and operate alongside this
situation because going to end
tomorrow now yeah I know that you've Al
taken a very concrete action internally
and organizationally support your
employees and it wasn't just okay guys
business as usual do your best and and
hope and you know take some vacation if
you need some time off you've actually
been very proactive with providing the
tools and the environment the atmosphere
whether it's from the infrastructure the
physical infrastructure and I and they
love to talk about that but also
supportive infrastructure from the
professional side so I'd love to to
understand a little bit what how what
did you do as an organization to support
the the the ability for people to not
just continue the business continuity
but to support their mental continuity
and get the support that they need sure
yeah so um we have today about 20% of
the company in uh in reserve duty right
uh I think that um we are relatively uh
uh the average age I think in the
company is probably 30 two I want to say
maybe maybe even a little bit less so a
lot of people are still in active our
reserves and we need to make sure that
um these uh people and their families
first and for all are getting uh uh the
support to operate because again it's
it's really challenging situation like
just imagine uh uh um young family with
two three kids uh where uh the mother or
the father is now abroad for 3 weeks
it's really really really complicated
right so uh making sure that they get
this support and and here my HR
operations have been phenomenal uh they
have immediately understood okay how how
how can we support uh uh this uh Team M
so there is constant communication uh
with the people at the front with the
people that Reserve s are the back uh
and most important with their families
so asking the sign if and other do you
need anything can we help in something
knowing that a lot of them are in really
really challenging uh times and also to
support uh uh uh practic uh in in in
practice every week uh we are sending
either their uh coupon for uh weekend
meem or complete uh uh supermarket
grocery uh uh bookes uh make sure do you
need anything or even if you don't we
are uh in things to support the families
knowing how challenging these few weeks
uh are for for for anyone the second
area is that the office have been open
from for from day one uh we have a very
very large uh uh sheltered area actually
uh because um all of the minus one floor
the basement floor is actually a shelter
uh area and uh in this uh area we've
also uh brought uh every every day uh
babysitter to the office so uh employees
with young kids can bring their uh kids
to work knowing that you've brought
babysitters to the office wow that's
incredible and the context is for
anybody who doesn't know the schools
have been closed and so little kids have
no they they're staying at home and so a
lot of people who even want would want
to go to work they can't because they
have to take care of their kids okay
that's really really cool yeah yeah
we've done it actually I think from this
second day or from the third day I think
from Tuesday uh already where the baby C
in the office um just understanding uh
that some of our our employees that the
significant other have been called to
reserve it's extremely complicated even
the ones that have not actually just so
complicated uh especially that this
happens after the holiday so when you
have like low duration that the kids
have been uh at home uh and that was
quite challenging for all of the young
uh uh
parents um the third area uh is you know
we always had to be to have
communication with their broad teams
because also the talent team in the US
in Europe uh uh none of not none of them
uh or at least most of them have not
went through uh similar situations in
the past so for us you know it's
unfortunate but this is the routine of
our life going through this uh uh uh
challenges uh but for them like they
they were not even sure hey what's going
on here in Israel can these people
operate so uh we have created a uh
internal uh communication uh Team uh
that is holding um a call every few days
with the global team to explain what is
happening here uh to explain uh how our
day-to-day uh looks like here in Israel
and also to provide some information on
kind of the history of the Israeli
Palestinian uh conflict so to make sure
that our Global team is educated uh that
they know a bit of the history and also
know how to support us for example uh um
we try to help them how to better
communicate with the Israeli team they
asked how can we know if you guys have
been uh are available or not so we made
sure that all of this which to us seems
like let's say more I would say regular
for them they know how to operate in
this uh uh situation and the last thing
that I think is the most most important
thing that we' have done is to help with
the mental support uh for the employees
so um every single one of the employees
um is now having super complicated time
if you know of people that have been
killed or been kidnapped or you have a
family that are in in this situation or
just people that are
struggling even if they don't have
anyone first or second degree but just
really complex so we had resilience
session with clinical
psychologists uh we have several options
for intimate one-onone conversation with
both clinical psychologist and uh
organizational uh uh consultant there
are actually a professional experts um
available for team members or uh these
type of areas of personal resilience the
PTSD uh to give them the tools to cope
with with with with the situation and to
be able
to operate in it I'm first of all
phenomenal all around and and I love how
intentional and you're act with with all
of this it's a I think the think it's a
it's a really um doesn't you know the
the intentionality behind that you're
rationale and you're thinking about why
you're making these efforts and the
impact these efforts have and how it
trickles down to the subjective
individual experience of every employee
and your taking into account not only
the Israeli employees but also the
global ones and how do you then make
sure that there is active communication
up to the point of okay are how do we
know if you're available how do we know
if if we can we're you know when when
are we keeping business as usual as when
and when we're not especially because of
everything that's unpredict so
unpredictable all the way to the
obviously the mental um the the mental
aspect of things and the resilience
aspect of of how you've been supporting
so that's I think really fantastic and
I'm curious of so what did you learn
about your company during this time what
did you learn about Talent what did you
learn about yourself sure it's a it's
it's an interesting time to to think
back know after this crazy
RS I think the thing that I've learned
more than anything else that this is a
group of amazing human beings more than
anything else by far because even if I'm
look at the third vertical of their
positive impact that we have done on on
the Israeli population uh this is the
thing that have made me the most
emotional
um I give you just example uh this week
uh the team is going to
volunteer uh in activities in the center
of
Israel uh actually helping in cucumber
Harvest
um because a lot of uh the people that
used to do this work and to help uh uh
harvesting all of the goods that are
coming for the ground uh a lot of them
are actually left asra or not willing uh
to go and work in uh in in the shield
and the team said look there are now
people that have been dramatically
negatively impacted by the situation uh
uh so we'll go probably a a couple of
thousands of people to support doing
this uh uh a physical work to support
people who just been less stable and
less fortunate from us compared to us in
this uh situation uh we have donated
throughout this uh last three weeks to
uh um uh organizations and companies
that are working uh uh actually in the
south of Israel and some of these
companies have completely been shut down
and try to get back to operations so we
have them with it equipment Financial uh
donation United atala far the community
zaka which are working with uh the did
H um um kibuts movement for the kibuts
uh uh around uh around the Border um and
and we've also uh generated a plan which
each uh Company employee that uh donates
money
uh to one of this or organizations the
company doubles uh this uh
donation uh so really the the the
ability is to provide as many support as
possible to
organizations uh that need support right
now and they've been less fortunate
because you know the challes of cyber
security have not been uh reduced and
the fact that we can you know as as uh
Hightech cber people can work from from
everywhere but you know it's not the
situation of every business they model
of businesses that have been
dramatically impacted uh is is is huge
so I feel that in a way if we can help
uh becoming the backbone uh to to
support organizations of been less
fortunate than I think it's Our
obligation uh and the last area is to
try and support bring a lot of the
information of what really happens here
in Israel and around the border to to
the world because I've seen uh many
people who are saying hey we don't
believe that this is the reality uh
these people in Israel are making up
some of these uh uh stories it's not
really what happened um so also a lot of
the global team members uh in the team
in Israel make sure that um this
information about the reality uh is
being spread uh to to the world and the
part of the reason why it's so important
because this allows Israel uh the
legitimacy uh to execute on on on the
tasks which are are now needed in order
to to destroy Hamas and to make sure
that uh the Civil the Civil population
in Israel would not be under this
ongoing threat uh anymore so a lot of
things uh but a lot of
things more than other thing I'm so so
so proud of these human beings that are
forming Talon uh the fact that the US
team cares every day covering for their
uh uh Israeli team Europe team the same
they actually have done donations to
support uh uh the activities that are
right now happening in in Israel to say
hey um no population should go through
the things that you guys and girls have
went through during the last uh few
weeks and uh we stand beside you uh
helping a good fight against
th Al this was such a privilege um
hearing your hearing how you've been
dealing with this over the last three
weeks um I think that it really just
speaks to The Testament of you know this
the this ecosystem that we're in and you
while you're in the growth stage and
you're so incredibly busy and you have a
global team global company you're you're
obviously you're you're just as devoted
devoted into this this Collective effort
and and um and not only pushing Talon as
a backbone of of cyber security in
nation B but also as a you know Shining
Light on how organizations can be
supportive of the ecosystem both
internally to its internal members but
also to the ecosystem at large and both
from what you're going to do this week
but overall the efforts you've done
working with other organizations um
donations uh and so all across the board
I'm leaving this conversation just very
inspired so thank you very much H making
me think of what er uh you know my role
as a leader and my role as a CEO how I
um you know communicate and the things
that I do so uh so thank you already for
that and continue making a positive
impact and uh thank you again to the
inspiration thank you my friend thank
you very
[Laughter]
much